fanni brought the hardware the Daytona
500 trophy there now that's not yours
that you had do you get a replica of
that or as I get the one from Victory
Lane when you win you take the one from
Victory Lane home and I believe this
might be the one that is up for grabs
this coming Sunday in Daytona for the
Daytona 500 where are those trophies at
home those trophies are sitting next to
the fireplace or in plain view if I walk
into your house how long does it take
before I know what you do for a living
probably 10 or 15 steps so what am I
gonna sue well there's the Daytona 500
trophies there's the 1999 Xfinity Series
trophy there's my 2004 Bristol Cup
trophy just to name a few there's about
six trophies seven trophies at home the
rest are over at Junior Motorsports okay
but does that make it tough for your
wife to decorate with that kind of
hardware I mean it's kind of hard to do
that deal yeah I think that's why
there's not all my trophies aren't at
the house I think um you know II guess
what I'm in the man cave
put it in the basement there let Amy
decorate the house yeah that's a good
idea
maybe we're heading that direction all
right full introduction here the
two-time Daytona 500 winner
you can catch Dale jr. he competes in
the Daytona 500 the great American race
at Sunday to 2 p.m. Eastern on Fox NBC
Sports group's coverage of the 2017
NASCAR scubs Cup Series kicks off
Saturday July 1st on NBC you've been to
hell and back though when you think
about it yeah I mean I didn't you had
the concussion and then we waited for
you to come back when did you start
feeling good or good enough to even talk
about well I had to I was pretty
transparent during the whole process and
that was number one the reason for that
was just for my own peace of mind I
didn't want people wondering about me or
making their own assumptions and getting
bad information out there so I thought
you know I'm in control of it with
social media and everything that we have
now at our fingertips I can control the
narrative and help people understand how
bad this is or what I'm dealing with and
so they're not is they're not impatient
I think my doctors told me they keep his
stress level down and that was gonna be
that was gonna help me recover quicker
if I was less
stressed and so I needed to get that off
my mind what people worrying about me
wondering about me pushing wondering
when I'm gonna return so if they could
see with their own eyes they could relax
and I could relax did you ever think
about retiring oh yeah I mean when you
when you're it at its worst when when
when you're feeling your worst you don't
want to do nothing that put you there
right so I wasn't blaming racing but I
didn't want to get back in a car cuz
because I was feeling this way that's
you know the car got me there in a sense
so what what's the worst day well you
know you get up you get up and you
almost can't get off the couch like your
balance is so bad that's standing up to
get off the couch
is turning a corner and you know walking
through through the kitchen turning a
corner open in the fridge turning your
head going from the fridge to the
cabinet just doing a 180 but you know I
almost fall over your eyes are shaking
with every step your eyes you can't keep
your eye on a target ten feet away
every step knocks your eyes off that
target and they kind of bounce around
and you can't find what you were looking
at you have to stand perfectly still to
be able to see anything did you get
nauseous
lots of yeah had some nausea I you know
every concussion is different every guy
has different symptoms some people have
different issues sight or mental issues
and what-have-you mood issues everybody
faces it a different way and and needs
different styles of treatment but yeah
when it was bad I you don't even care
about racing I know it's hard to
understand or hard to real you know what
that means but when you're sick you just
want to be better I had my wedding
coming up on New Year's Eve
hunting season was coming up in November
I had all these things I'm like I told
my doctor I said there's I don't want to
I don't want to have any symptoms at my
wedding you know that's all I cared
about was just being able to go through
that with a clear mind and be able to
enjoy it you know every day was not even
tolerable with those symptoms and so I
wanted you know and he's like alright
man you know we're
work hard you're gonna work hard we're
gonna fix it and we did and bye-bye
November the days were tolerable all
this started in in July but I'll you
know the day's became tolerable around
November you know starting in November I
think you know I got into deer stand
um you know 20 feet in the air holding
the bow and arrow I got to be able to
stand up on this tiny little platform to
shoot and all that and I felt confident
enough about my balance at that point
that I was checking I started checking
boxes like I man this is I'm gonna be
fine you know what was that first time
behind the wheel
December 14th we went to Darlington and
ran for five hours probably 200 laps and
the first three or four laps felt it
didn't fit like a glove you know he
didn't it felt I felt it felt a little
cumbersome I didn't have any symptoms
but I just felt raw and and not you know
when you go to even when you go to even
after racing for year after year after
year every time you go to Bristol for
example it's so fast that you're
mentally takes you about 30 laps to sort
of get caught up to what you're seeing
your mind to get in that mode and see
things happening so quickly to be able
to react to them just right and that's
kind of what I went through the first
three laps the first three or four laps
I was getting up to speed mentally with
what I was seeing and feeling in the car
by the end of the day I felt like me in
the car one piece like I me in the car
where one piece and and that's exactly
how you want to feel I felt completely
comfortable and everything I was feeling
football players try to hide concussions
you know I don't know if you have a
different respect for those who play
football but this isn't your first
concussion did you tried to hide the
concussion the this concussion here I
wanted to I didn't try to hide it
because I've kind of been through that
before in 2012 I layered two concussions
together and gotten some real dangerous
territory doing that I tried to hide a
concussion from a test at Kansas in 2012
and then I got in a wreck for weeks
later and got in some real danger was
that concussion related right yeah there
I had a concussion tried to race through
it and gotten another crash and another
hard lick and layered two concussions
together and that's very dangerous when
you get them close together like that if
you get one you need to get out you know
if we're starting to understand and
learn the new new ways of approaching
this obviously you got to get out and
recover and I didn't allow myself to do
that and being injured and getting into
another incident was the worst thing you
can do so I I got this concussion over
this was a cushion that accumulated
through several accidents this past year
it wasn't just one event so it was a lot
of wrecks that brought on this problem
and it can't all the concussions I ever
had in the past you wreck you knew you
had it like you knew it the minute you
got stopped and everything slowed down
that something wasn't just right right
this one I felt great I had a few more
wrecks in the season than I normally did
and those are cumulative wrecks and
impacts brought on these symptoms that
I'd never felt before in prior incidents
prior concussions these these symptoms I
tried to link to allergies and so yeah
so I had my eyes hurt my eyes were kind
of burning my vision was blurry and I'd
started getting allergies the last
couple years something a man these
allergies maybe I'm getting worse and
worse and worse I was talking to my
teammate Jimmie Johnson who deals with
allergies and he had yeah there's those
are the symptoms I went to my family
doctor got prescribed meds for allergies
he's like yeah it looks like allergies
and so I called my owner the next day
and I said something's going on I'm not
sure what it is he said go to dr. petit
who is the neurosurgeon in charlotte
that we all go see when we have issues
he's I said you're right I should
probably go because if this gets any
worse I'm not gonna be able to drive
starting to feel dizzy and all this he
called himself the king - dr. petty dr.
petty he's no relation to Richard but
you know if he thinks he's the king - he
is the king he is he is my dad trusted
him for years he's been in the sport as
a trusted neurosurgeon and doctor for
decades
so I knew I'd worked with him in 2012 to
get through that concussion so I knew I
was in good hands but it didn't dawn on
me like this is from crashing you know
that because I before when I would wreck
I knew I had it and that's what I'd
gotten used to and so this past season
when I was wrecking I get that car feel
fine I'm like I'm fine I don't have a
concussion just going through you know
just another crash go to the next race
and this kind of came on much like a flu
or illness would really slowly yeah and
then what do you think your dad would
have advised you to do I don't know you
know he because he he drove through
everything
he drove was broke neck Benny break his
focus sternum yeah
broke a sternum I you know I never we
never talked about concussions and head
injuries the the whole it wasn't that I
didn't even know if he ever had any you
know I knew he broke his collar bones
like I broke both collarbones in a wreck
in 79 broke his femur in 82 you know
he's had some bad crashes but we never I
never saw him I mean I was around him
enough that I would have noticed but I
never saw him with a concussion or wit
or witnessed any I've never witnessed
anyone with this type of situation
before so and the stigma and the whole
attitude toward how you just be raced
through it you worked through it yeah it
was the same way in all sports yeah but
that's slowly changing especially with I
mean you know you can certainly race
with you won't you would try your best
to race with injuries but now that we've
learned what we've learned over the last
several years especially through what
they've done in the NFL and all these
great doctors that are that are trying
to treat these folks that that are
getting injured we've learned so much to
be able to be a little bit smarter about
it we'll continue with a Dale jr. his
wife Amy is here we have a quiz for
aiming awesome since you're newlyweds
yeah fun
does she know everything about you
awesome yeah hey Paulie how long have we
research these questions 14 minutes all
right
that's long for us alright so we'll
continue with Dale jr.
no more concussion questions okay how's
that sure we'll talk Redskins if you
want I love rats games let's talk it
yeah but you might need a new
quarterback there I'm a little worried
about that situation maybe you buy the
Redskins I don't have that kind of money
oh you don't know I don't I don't I
don't have that kind of money you're
know people who have that kind of money
well you got the friends friends family
the France family I don't know I don't
know that I would want the France fam I
want to race NASCAR and the France
family own the Redskins to be a little
weird for me okay yeah maybe you
wouldn't LeBron James goodbye the
Redskins knows that LeBron being the
majority in there too watching on
DirecTV the audience Network channel 239
or the NBC Sports Network you're seeing
two lovebirds they're just staring at
each other it must be nice to be in love
there Jr is especially you know Amy and
I been together a long time so we we
know each other really well she knows me
better than anybody else and all right
full introduction here Amy's Dale's new
wife got married in January of course
Dale is the driver the 88 Nationwide
Insurance Chevrolet for Hendrick
Motorsports we came up with a quiz we
spent about 15 minutes on this so
obviously a lot of time on this so aim
I'm gonna see how well you know jr. all
right Dale
Dale's middle name is and his first name
is okay first name is Ralph did you
think about going with that is that your
grandfather's name
yeah Ralph Lee Earnhardt Lee's my
grandfather did you ever think about
staying with Ralph to stay away from the
Dale Dale senior well you know I had
that come you don't think about that
when you're four or five years old make
that decision for you early okay okay so
your dad said you're your Dale Jack yeah
you had no choice then if you had a
choice I like Dale jr. emotion it's open
some doors right uh yeah
literally Dale played what sport in high
school Amy back up soccer player yeah I
was a fullback I didn't know how to
I had no ball control so I couldn't play
wing or anything like that but I could
stop a guy from scoring I mean that's
pretty easy alright just getting his way
yeah kick the ball so I play fullback
but I was I was on the bench in high
school Dale was an A student a B student
or a C student C student C student is
correct that's three for three
Dale prefers to wear baseball hats
backwards or forwards both oh no I
thought it was backward have you
graduated to floor now I got a picture
three weeks ago Paulie is that right
yeah three weeks ago you went back
driver intros keep it home cuz it's
gonna blow off background around sixty
miles an hour so you end up on the
ground
Dale's favorite sandwich is well no
sandwich I'm making my races yeah I
don't make that banana and males yeah
that is a North Carolina it is I think
people in in the south Atlanta New
Orleans I had all kinds of people that
knew what it was but anybody north of
Virginia or west of the Mississippi
thought it was the worst idea in the
world well didn't Elvis eat those kind
of Elvis Elvis ate banana mayo peanut
butter fried Oh fried okay deep-fry the
whole sandwich pound of bacon - you had
a pound of bacon sandwich deep fried
that's no joke which of Dale's relatives
had the most kick-ass mustache in
history yeah there you go
well done anyway we got one more oh you
got another oh yeah I was gonna ask
the final and most important question
okay I saw them on NFL Sunday I got you
a Redskins Jersey to wear whose Redskins
Jersey do you wear nice got that diesel
how is he when the Redskins lose how is
he more beers consumed how many how many
you know NASCAR drivers went to the
wedding boy or Clint Boyer was there
accomplished Denny Hamlin Danica Ricky
who else fun yeah we were on the dance
floor we had the offices on New Year's
so we had this big New Year's party
afterwards and I look to my right and
they are like professional dancing but
does he dance like he drives like all
over the place yeah but it was like a
party with purpose like this dance
I mean they weren't just goofing off
dancing like the rest of those who they
rehearsed this do classes or something
don't you think that seems like it he
had sits very specifically yeah Danica
do you some dancer I'm sure yeah just
drop it like it's hot a little bit okay
nerves let's say before Sunday's race
Daytona as opposed to getting there
walking down that aisle how can compare
the nerves between the two yeah with
with getting married I knew I was gonna
win you don't know she's your checkered
play all confidence in the world but how
nervous are you gonna be on Sunday you
know I'm suturing everything you've gone
through
oh yeah I mean with the injury and
everything coming back I'll be nervous
about myself my performance my decisions
my choices cause in plate racing
everything's about instinct and making
the right choice to do the right thing
in the draft and you know so I'll be
make I want to do a good
to make sure that I put forth a good
account of myself my team they're gonna
you know we got a great car we're
starting on the front row it's fast so I
mean I'm always I mean I mean it's human
nature I think to be nervous I've always
kind of been nervous before qualifying
before races it's nothing that I ever
got used to so that those nerves will be
piling up what about you Amy I'm as
nervous as he is when he's nervous I'm
nervous it's kind of an energy that
passes around the room you know and you
have no control over anything that's at
least he's driving right you have to sit
where do you watch I watching our motor
coach we couple with our dogs and
nobody's watching me in there I can yell
the TV as loud as I want to and I
usually have the TV pretty low and I
listen to the radio so I can listen to
what he's saying
with the spotters and everything in the
car would you want your kids to drive oh
yeah you know the only thing about it is
is super expensive I mean to be honest
I've got a lot of friends buddies they
have kids that aren't you know they're
getting them into racing and it is a
very expensive activity even at a young
age for a kid so to try to it's a great
play it's a great way to treat
sportsmanship and it's and to teach
sportsmanship so I know that my nieces
learn quite a bit from winning and
losing when they race so I think it's a
great a great father-son or
father-daughter kind of activity but man
I mean is it expensive just to race at a
low level as a 10 12 year old kinds of
dollars you know and it's just not like
it used to be when I was started up when
I started up me and my brother built the
streets talking with racing for 400
bucks built a car and everything motor
and you can't do that who's a better
driver on the street you worry me
typically I'm driving he's on his iPad
yeah you have to drive fine we have a
crashed yet same yet yeah neither one of
us had any problems Tim oh yeah she's
I'm really really slow and lazy on the
highway she's all she's much faster than
I am that's true the last time we rode
together I had to tell him to speed up
he wasn't going to be
I get into pondering and thinking and
just cruising yeah and cuz I'd get a
race you know for a living so I go
faster oh you race for a living yeah so
that's you know I get my speed out on
the race if I said you could win the
Daytona 500 or the Redskins could win
the Superbowl I would take the Daytona
500 every time I love the Redskins it's
been since 91 though since we want to do
both so what's another year if I win
today talk about if you're guaranteeing
me the win at the Daytona 500 what if
what if I give I give you this Daytona
500 but I don't give you anymore Daytona
500 but the Redskins will win a Super
Bowl I'll take this Daytona 500s if both
you would yeah okay that's a guaranteed
win would you now let's say you have a
successful season let's say you win the
championship would you consider a John
Elway walk away when I retire on the
stage in Vegas hell yeah you would
really I mean why wouldn't it be the
best way yeah to go out yes on top but
it's rare when guys do that I know but
it's rare anybody wants a championship
at 43 years old
do you old no not yet I'm AM what goes
first on a driver I don't know you know
I've always wondered I've always wanted
to talk to guys that have retired Dale
Jarrett and other people that I trust
that would shoot me straight as to what
happens and where does the lose passion
do you lose skill do you lose you know
what is it that sort of Wayne's first
when you know that you're not doing the
job anymore that some males needs to get
in there and do it I've had hadn't had
that conversation yet but I certainly
would love to what would your dad be
doing now I think we'd still have de I
knew be working would you work with I
would hope that I would still be there
I think di would still be around he was
such a great businessman I have all the
faith in the world at that place would
would still be fielding race teams and
and have happy sponsors and have had a
lot of race wins in between you know
then and now and I would love to still
be a part of it
wonder how he would have retired though
I get the feeling it you know as the as
great a competitor I think he already
had his plan
oh no yeah I think he did I think that
he had his plan I think and there's a
few people not me included but I think
there's a few people that he may have
shared that with as to you know
particularly in his inner circle as far
as his businesses go as to what he was
gonna do driving wise over the next
couple of years and I think he had a
plan in his mind to to scale it back and
it wasn't about a year or two more of
racing before he's gonna retire do you
bring racing home with you that's a bad
habit yeah so it's great win home it's a
great habit because every time we win
all the guys on the team I don't I don't
care if it takes them till four o'clock
in the morning to get home we have a
party in my basement every time we win
we've celebrated in the basement if it's
you know whenever they get home I'm
waiting I'll wait for them and had the
beer cold the worst but the worst thing
is is I think the one thing that I
struggle with is yeah when I don't run
well I bring it home and I can't get
over it until I can redeem myself which
means I I got to get back in the car
which doesn't happen till the next
weekend so it's it takes a couple days
to get over you've changed a lot though
in the last two years just from me
talking to you and observing I thought
the Tommy Tomlinson interview and ESPN
The Magazine was spectacular and any I
have to credit you I think for a lot of
this I think he's you know it feels like
he's found himself you know yeah you
know maybe you're acting your age junior
maybe that's what it is I hope to get
there I feel like you found out a whole
lot about yourself in the last two years
yeah and he's been a huge huge part of
that and you know she I was such a
introvert and wouldn't expose myself to
just normal experiences day to day and
she's helped me kind of get out of my
shell and show me how to be more
comfortable in and around people and and
just get over my social anxieties I had
a lot of anxiety and social
situations and she's helped me get more
more confidence to be able to get out
and do things so when you get in front
of people
like your your fine race in a car 180
miles an hour
yeah but if I put you in a crowd with
twenty people it's it's weird yeah I
have social anxiety I think and it you
know any I wouldn't go anywhere I wasn't
comfortable going and and I prolong that
for so many years and it and so yeah had
a lot of catching up to do and Amy's
helped me kind of get out and be myself
all these other you know personal
experiences going through the injuries
and stuff to his helps you learn a lot
about yourself and get your priorities
sort of straightened out what's
important that's all been a big deal and
she's like I said she spearheaded all
that she was she's been there every
every minute ever since I got hurt all
the way through the process of recovery
the workouts the evaluations the
conversations and meetings with every
doctor family member she was in every
single one of those well but if you
think about it I mean every year you go
back to where your father died and you
know people are gonna ask you questions
you know it's coming you just don't know
when it's coming and I don't know how
and I've said that before to you a
couple years ago just to process that
nobody else can understand that but
you've and and I don't know if we make
too big if I make too big of a deal of
it but I think it's remarkable that you
have allowed yourself to open up to
process it and I don't know how long it
took to do that but I couldn't imagine
trying to do something like that yeah I
think the the opening up and being
honest and transparent at first you're
kind of nervous to be judged but
eventually if you don't give people
information they make their own
assumptions and decisions about what
you're going through and that's
dangerous too and sometimes they can
begin correct and wrong and bad
information can get out there rumor can
become fact and especially in the world
we live in with social media and stuff
just you know there's just flying around
out there
so I'm just trying you know I think
going through the process of recovery
and everything being so transparent and
showing people what we're dealing with
helped me have peace of mind that I knew
people weren't worrying about what I was
doing they knew they knew the
information and knew what I was dealing
with once again I credit you aim you had
to do there's something different
in the last two years and that's pretty
remarkable and you're in love - yeah
yeah yeah good luck this weekend Thanks
thank you and if you're watching by the
way he brought in the Daytona 500 trophy
how much that way Oh 30 40 pounds really
let's see if she picks it up on Sunday
no pressure
the driver of the number 88 Nationwide
Insurance Chevrolet for Hendrick
Motorsports sees the Dale jr. and his
great way thing thank you for coming the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience